this morning about 800,000 federal
workers will miss their second paychecks
because of the partial government
shutdown celebrity chef Jose Andres is
feeding thousands of furloughed
employees who cannot afford to buy food
David Wagner was spending day 35 of the
shut down at Andres pop up world central
kitchen that's in Washington DC David
good morning to you nobody thought it
would come to this good morning Gail
they put me to work they said instead of
standing here look and start stirring so
I said okay here we go this is a quinoa
vegetable soup I'm gonna hand this off
to you as I show our friends the rest of
it most every chef every worker in the
kitchen like Miss Lisa right here is a
volunteer right a lot of them are
furloughed workers so we're inside the
facility where chef Andres has been
operating since last Wednesday when they
open it's a pop-up and I want to walk
you through it people already starting
to show up they're getting the food
ready at 11 a.m. they start serving they
come in the door and the line by the way
yesterday was about a hundred to two
hundred throughout the day they come in
the door they check your ID and you walk
right through the line the menus up
there chicken sandwich quinoa bowls soup
you come through it sit to go bagged and
they also have some simple stuff like
snacks you go through there's coffee and
then you're out the door
less than five minutes and on the other
side of the building Gail there's
actually a place where they're giving
away feminine products pet food diapers
essential stuff and again a lot of these
people who are being served
they served 11,000 people on Wednesday
alone a lot of the people who are being
served are coming back to help do the
serving
David I'm thinking you need to go back
to the kitchen since you clearly know
how to stir that was one nice long
camera shot thank you thank you very
much I could do that I know you can
nicely done